for over a decade I have studied young
people that have been pushed out of
school so-called dropouts as they end up
failed by the education system they're
on the streets where they're vulnerable
to violence police harassment police
brutality and incarceration I follow
these young people for years at a time
across institutional settings to try to
understand what some of us call the
school to Prison Pipeline when you look
at a picture like this of young people
who are in my study you might see
trouble I mean one of the boys has a
bottle of liquor in his hand he's 14
years old and it's a school day other
people when they see this picture might
see gangs thugs delinquents criminals
but I see it different I see these young
people's through a perspective that
looks at the assets that they bring to
the education system so will you join me
in changing the way we label young
people from at risk to at promise
how do I know that these young people
have the potential and the promise to
change I know this because I am one of
them you see I grew up in dire poverty
in the inner city without a father he
abandoned me before I was even born we
were on welfare
sometimes homeless many times hungry by
the time I was fifteen years old had
been incarcerated in juvie three times
for three felonies my best friend had
already been killed and soon after while
I'm standing next to my uncle he gets
shot and as I'm waiting for the
ambulance to arrive for over an hour
he bleeds to death on the street I had
lost faith and hope in the world and I
had given up on the system because the
system had failed me I had nothing to
offer and no one had anything to offer
me
I was fatalistic I didn't even think I
could make it to my 18th birthday the
reason I'm here today is because a
teacher that cared reached out and
managed to tap into my soul this teacher
mrs. Russ she was the kind of teacher
that was always in your business
she was the kind of teacher that was
like Victor I'm here for you whenever
you're ready I wasn't ready but she
understood one basic principle about
young people like me
we're like oysters we're only going to
open up when we're ready and if you're
not there when we're ready we're going
to clam back up miss russ was there for
me
she was culturally relevant she
respected my community my people my
family I told her a story about my uncle
Ruben he would take me to work with him
because I was broken he knew I needed
some money
he collected glass bottles for a living
4:00 in the morning on a school they
would throw the glass bottles in the
back of his van and the bottles would
break in my hands and arms and start to
bleed and my tennis shoes and and pants
would get all bloody and I was terrified
and in pain and I would stop working and
my uncle he would look at me in the eyes
and he would say to me mijo estamos
buscando vida we're searching for a
better life we're trying to make
something out of nothing mrs. Russ
listened to my story welcomed it into
the classroom and said Victor this is
your power this is your potential your
family your culture your community have
taught you a hard work ethic and you
will use it to empower yourself in the
academic world so you can come back and
empower your community with mrs. Rosa's
help I ended up returning to school I
even finished my credits on time and
graduated with my class
but Miss Russ said to me right before
graduation Victor I'm so proud of you
I knew you could do it now it's time to
go to college college me man what does
this teacher smoke and thinking I'm
going to college I applied with the
mentors and support she provided got a
letter of acceptance and one of the
paragraphs read you've been admitted
under probationary status
I said probation I'm already on
probation that's all matter
it was academic probation not criminal
probation but what the teachers like
miss Russ do to succeed with young
people like the ones I studied I propose
three strategies the first let's get rid
of our deficit perspective and education
these people come from a culture of
violence a culture of poverty these
people are at risk these people are true
these people are empty containers for us
to feel with knowledge they have the
problems we have the solutions number
two let's value the stories that young
people bring to the schoolhouse their
stories of overcoming unsurmountable
odds are so powerful and I know you know
some of these stories these very same
stories and experiences already have
grit character and resilience in them so
let's help young people refine those
stories let's help them be proud of who
they are because our education system
welcomes their families their cultures
their communities and the skill set
they've learned to survive and of course
the third strategy being the most
important resources we have to provide
adequate resources to young people grit
alone isn't going to cut it you can sit
there and tell me all you want
hey man pick yourself up by the
bootstraps
but if I was born without any straps on
my boots how am I supposed to pick
myself up job training mentoring
counseling teaching young people to
learn from their mistakes instead of
criminalizing them and dragging them out
of their classrooms like animals how
about this
I propose that we implement restorative
justice in every high school in America
so we went out to test these ideas in
the community of watts in LA with 40
young people that have been pushed out
of school
William was one of them William was the
kind of kid that had been given every
label he had dropped out he was a gang
member of criminal and when we met him
he was very resistant but I remember
what miss Rusk used to say hey I'm here
for you whenever you're ready so over
time over time he began to open up and I
remember the day that he made the switch
we were in a large group and a young
lady in our program was crying because
she told us her powerful story of her
dad being killed and then his body being
shown in the newspaper the next day and
as she's crying I don't know what to do
so I give her her space and William had
enough he slammed his hands on the desk
and he said hey everybody group hug
group hug
this young lady's tears and pain turned
into joy and laughter knowing that her
community had her back and William had
now learned that he did have a purpose
in life to help to heal the souls of
people in his own community he told us a
story we refined his story to go from
being the story of a victim to being the
story of a survivor that has overcome
adversity we placed high value on it
William went on to finish high school
get his security guard certificate to
become a security guard and is now
working at a local school district
mrs. roses mantra her mantra was always
when you teach to the heart the mind
will follow the great writer Khalil
Gibran says out of suffering have
emerged the greatest Souls the massive
characters are seared with scars I
believe that in this education
revolution that we are talking about we
need to invite the souls of the young
people that we work with and once
they're able to refine identify their
grit resilience and character that
they've already developed their academic
performance will improve let's believe
in young people let's provide them the
right kinds of resources I'll tell you
what my teacher did for me she believed
in me so much that she tricked me into
believing in myself thank you